Want some examples? Almost anything done by
a magician. You know, magicians are masters
at maniuplating your attention, providing misleading signifiers,
and misleading affordances. Secret doors. For example, hidden
behind a book case that swings to the side when one of the books
is pulled. Another one, many homes or
business display fake video cameras and security warnings.
They're trying to scare away criminals but without the expense
of putting in a real camera or hiring a real
security company. And I own a fake watch. Now, that
is, it's a real watch. It tells good time. But it
has extra buttons and dials that make it look like
an expensive chronometer. The buttons don't even move, and the
dials, well, they're just printed pictures of dials. It was
given to me as a present, and it certainly fooled me.